I mean you know hearing about this this
extraordinary journey this adventure
that they know that you both been on you
know and here you are you're at dances
with films your view just for major film
last night you know what are you looking
forward to next like what sort of on the
horizon that continues to get you
excited as it relates to this film uh uh
was a release of this movie yeah getting
more audience this is to see it yeah
what's been great is we've had people
who've seen the film who just are so
touched by it whether sometimes good or
bad like it just incites such
conversation we actually had a friend of
ours come up to us he's like I was
standing on a poster after the screening
and a woman who I don't know just came
up to me and felt like she needed to
just say things do there's so much she
needed to say after the film you that
your film inspired out of her you're
getting strangers to talk to strangers
like you know and I think that just it
means a lot when you when you can when
you can say something that incites
dialogue and so I just it's so exciting
to just try and find ways for people to
see it whether that be they like it or
don't you know I just I just want to and
we're trying a new thing with you know
putting it online we're just literally
just thinking outside the box how do we
get is we we have a film that's like
rabbit hole but we don't have ryan
gosling in it so how do you get that out
there you know and we go sorry I'm
thinking blue bouncy bed time Ryan
Gosling rapaho Nicole came in
but yes I mean it's like we're so we're
just trying literally i'm just picturing
ryan gosling like in the backups i seen
a rabbit hole like yes yes well and all
films Ryan Gosling she just should be
yeah absolutely completely great come on
yeah yes it just is it's literally just
trying to find big markets and little
regional festivals that fit our film and
just try to get it out there's any way
we know how yeah and then i would love
to someday not have to beg to make a
movie like I would love to Sunday just
be able to you know have a modest enough
funds that don't include our credit
cards yeah we can say I would just love
did not have pay card debt to my
community that BLT but I think that said
you remember everybody is just to be
able and I'm I don't want to you know
make kajillion amount of money I just
want to be able to make the next project
yeah actually we were hanging out with
with some people before your screening
and Jonathan cheaper was like well howdy
how do you define success and I was like
oh to make another one you're like yeah
I think I'll my grace get that yeah i
mean great to not have a date on a
rubber but I don't mind have a just a
job that's why make another movie yeah
yeah
you